[Music]
well it's just hours before the red
carpet and check out this cool at
exclusively scored Olivia and Buddy does
to get ready with her and she's been
eating cookies I'm not proud of myself
wait a minute what it is something that
gives me a lot of stress I see people
working out and onstop on Instagram
talking about their cleanses and their
diets all for the Met Ball and I had
french fries the last two nights every
time people talk about how good they are
I want to be the bad Olivia is wearing
this golden chainmail dress which is
custom made by H&M it's got 70 feet of
bold rings linked together by hand and a
3 foot train these are the accessories
including this headdress and we do have
this built-in corset because we really
wanted to have that feeling of armor and
have everything pulled in together
honestly the bathroom at the Met is
really interesting because you go in
there and there is like everyone it can
bring up some like you know high school
anxiety of being over new girl and yoga
but you just kind of you learn to blend
in and just watch but what is Olivia's
best Met Gala memory first people were
screaming Olivia Olivia over here over
here over here and then within seconds
somebody goes you know but I was like
but you were just saying nice things to
me look over my shoulder and it's a mall
and George Knight I thought it was the
funniest I was like this is literally
the highlight of my night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]